six months after he was first arrested
Andrew Tate knows his fate now charged
with some of the most serious crimes
imaginable rape human trafficking and
organized crime
Tate is under house arrest at his home a
converted industrial unit in the suburbs
of Bucharest his response to the charges
came through social media first saying
I'm sure this case has absolutely
nothing to do with stealing my wealth
and then telling nearly 7 million
Twitter followers this isn't about
whether you like me or not this is about
all of us today it's me tomorrow it's
you nobody is safe from these lies
chicks just stuck in our house sitting
there bored completely in love with me
and of course they don't go out they're
not allowed out Tate's profile is built
on online content that's targeted at
teenage boys and young men critics claim
it's misogynistic violent and dangerous
it's alleged that he and his brother
Tristan used physical and mental
intimidation to force women into
producing pornographic content
it's why they allege victims and those
who've worked with them insist that
these women are victims of violence
trafficking and coercion sex trafficking
is not always someone being Locked In
Chains and held in a dungeon quite
typically the most common form of uh
coercion that traffickers use is
psychological manipulation so someone
can go to a grocery store or even look
like they're smiling in a video but be
being sex trafficked it's now up to the
Romanian courts to decide if and when
this trial will take place
Andrew Tate has molded himself into a
Brash Unapologetic celebrity a court
will decide if he's actually a violent
Criminal Adam Parsons Sky News